bon ben écoutez chers amis nous allons
commencer et merci Monsieur de nous
avoir rejoints donc nous poursuivons
notre cycle d'audition sur la question
de l'Aude débuter le 28 février dernier
avec aujourd'hui votre audition
cette édition publique fait l'objet
d'une captation audiovisuelle et d'un
compte-rendu officiel donc monsieur
Alexis guilpar merci d'être avec nous je
vous prie d'excuser notre président Rémi
pointeau qui ne peut qui ne peut être
parmi nous aujourd'hui et donc Evelyne
Perrot que je suis
assuré la présidence de cette séance
notre audition s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la mission d'information sur la
gestion durable de l'eau demandée par le
groupe socialiste qui aboutira à la
remise d'un rapport fin juin début
juillet
pardon nous sommes particulièrement
intéressés par l'analyse des politiques
de l'eau et par les propositions que
vous entendez mettre sur la table les
associations environnementales sont
représentées dans les instances de
gouvernance de l'eau agence de bassins
commissions locales de l'eau ou encore
élaboration du projet territoire gestion
haut
quelles sont les priorités que vous
défendez est-il possible d'aboutir à des
consensus locaux qui engagent toutes les
parties quel regard portez-vous sur le
plan haut de 53 mesures qui vient
d'annoncer le président de la République
nous vous avons envoyé un questionnaire
qui pourra servir de tram pour notre
entretien donc je vais passer la parole
à notre rapporteur RVG pour vous
préciser les attentes de notre mission
nos interrogations et ce que nous
attendons de notre échange de ce jour je
vous remercie beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente chez Evelyne
merci donc je renouvelle mes
remerciements pour votre disponibilité
on est dans un format toujours un peu
contraint au niveau horaire on a les
questions gouvernement qui démarrent à
15h donc on va se permettre d'avoir une
audition on va dire assez dynamique pour
aller à effectivement à l'essentiel
peut-être pour commencer bien sûr si
vous pouvez à la fois vous présenter et
présenter effet ne et puis nous indiquer
déjà dans ce premier chapeau les sujets
majeurs sur lesquels vous souhaitez
effectivement nous alerter puis après on
va rentrer plus précisément dans le
questionnaire qui vous a été transmis on
est dans un moment intéressant
politiquement au sens noble du terme sur
le sujet puisque
d'abord on vient un cycle de sécheresse
anormal
normalement long pourrait-on dire qui
nous préoccupe aussi sur l'exercice 2023
le plan haut du gouvernement par
l'expression du président de la
République
donc été présenté assez récemment il
avait été repoussé de plusieurs de
plusieurs mois un certain nombre de
travaux vont s'y sur portent également
sur le sujet donc on est sur un moment
intéressant en termes de résonance pour
approfondir ces questions là
donc voilà aussi tout l'intérêt de cette
mission d'information même je vous en
prime alors donc merci de m'accueillir
et de modifier donc je suis Alexis
guilpar je suis au sein de la fédération
France Nature Environnement l'animateur
du réseau thématique au milieu aquatique
donc voilà je fais vivre un peu toutes
les questions liées à l'eau dans notre
mouvement qui compte plus de 9000
associations
et voilà près de près de 900 000
adhérents via ces associations qui se
fédèrent à la fois dans des fédérations
territoriales ou des associations
membres nationales donc c'est un
mouvement assez conséquent c'est de la
grosse Fédération des associations de
protection de la nature en France
et à ce titre on est effectivement assez
présent sur les questions d'eau à la
fois sur l'ensemble des comités de
bassins en métropole dans la dans la
majorité des commissions locales de
l'eau et donc très investi de longue
date sur ces questions
un peu à tous les échelons
comme vous l'avez dit c'est un moment
assez assez clé pour les pour les
politiques de l'eau puisqu'on a à la
fois des séquences de concertation et de
planification qui sont déroulées sur les
années passées il y a eu la mise en
place des nouveaux âges il y a eu
d'abord le cycle des assises de l'eau
toute cette séquence qui a créé vraiment
une une certaine dynamique autour de la
question de l'avenir de l'eau il y a eu
aussi la voilà la séquence du varen de
l'eau qui a abordé cette question là
plutôt sous l'angle principalement de
son usage agricole et maintenant le plan
haut donc qui était annoncé
il y a quelques jours et comment face à
cet ensemble de concertation et de
planification politique on appréhende
aussi à la fois les la sécheresse
convient actuellement on a vécu en 2022
qu'on risque de revivre dans une grosse
partie de nos territoires en 2023 mais
pour les années suivantes à venir parce
que ce qui était l'exception risque pour
beaucoup de nos territoires de devenir
finalement une norme donc voilà c'est
toute cette question là évidemment au
coeur au coeur des enjeux la question de
la raréfaction de la ressource et donc
de comment est-ce qu'on préserve cette
ressource comment est-ce que on met en
place des politiques de sobriété et
comment la ressource qui reste
disponible on la partage équitablement
entre les usages tout en préservant les
milieux
et comment aussi on fait vraiment le ce
lien entre la qualité et la quantité
puisque finalement ces deux sujets qui
sont complètement liés c'est à dire s'il
y a une ressource qui se raréfie et qui
et si on se met à plus prélevé les
polluants vont se concentrer les
habitats pour la faune et la flore vont
aussi être plus impactés donc qui a
vraiment tout ce lien entre à la fois
bouleversement climatique du cycle de
l'eau les usages qu'on en a et les les
effets des activités humaines sur
lesquelles il faut absolument travailler
pour revenir à ce gros objectif de la
directive cadre européenne de qui vise à
atteindre un bon état des masses d'eau
et qui un objectif qui malheureusement
pour beaucoup pour beaucoup de masse
d'eau et repousser donc c'est à dire ça
reste plutôt un horizon qui qui semble
reculer à chaque fois qu'on avance dans
le temps donc quels moyens on se donne
aussi vis-à-vis de ses objectifs là qui
sont finalement des réponses pour pour
s'adapter au changement climatique et
pour l'atténuer puisque c'est donc je
pense j'aurais l'occasion d'en parler à
un peu de nos échanges au cœur
finalement des questions d'eau il y a la
question de
vision comme une ressource à utiliser à
partager ou comme d'un milieu au cœur de
la question du cycle de l'eau et de des
interactions entre
changements changements climatique au
biodiversité il y a cette
cet état de nos écosystèmes cet état des
des sols qui sont qui sont très dégradés
et finalement il y a beaucoup de
solutions qui passent par la
restauration de ces écosystèmes par
redonner vraiment toutes leurs
fonctionnalités au cours d'eau aux zones
humides et à l'ensemble de nos sols dans
leur capacité à mieux infiltrer mieux
restituer l'eau aux nappes souterraines
mieux aussi stocker l'eau puisque
les sols stockent bien plus d'eau que
l'ensemble de nos cours d'eau
bien donc pour avancer peut-être dans le
questionnaire un premier chapeau un
premier parti on va dire plutôt sur la
gouvernance
donc vous participez aux différents
travaux aujourd'hui sur l'élaboration
des stages des stages nous aimerions
avoir votre analyse
aujourd'hui de ces outils des méthodes
et puis des process ce que vous pensez
que lors de clinaison notamment au
niveau des clés commission locale de
l'eau est-ce que c'est déclinaisons sont
satisfaisantes est-ce qu'il faudrait les
améliorer
vous-même sur la gouvernance ça c'est
pas dans le questionnaire mais vous avez
une gouvernance complexe parce que vous
êtes une fédération d'associations qui
n'ont pas toujours d'ailleurs les mêmes
positions un certain moment donc vous
devez avoir parfois
quelques débats ou des sujets de
cristallisation lorsque vous avez pu
évoquer d'ailleurs vous parliez des
quantités de la qualité en disant qu'il
faut arriver à concilier effectivement
c'est ces sujets là j'en rajouterais un
troisième qui est les usages qualité
quantité et les usages et aujourd'hui
c'est toute la conflictualité en
l'occurrence qui qui est posée parfois
sur la nature des
usages donc c'est ce sont des éléments
importants et pour boucler peut-être ce
premier niveau de gouvernance que
pensez-vous aussi donc des ptge
qui tendent à se développer aujourd'hui
quels sont les plus et les moins qu'elle
pourrait vous propositions pour
éventuellement améliorer les projets ou
les démarches territoriales
alors sur ça fait beaucoup de questions
d'un coup sur les stages
c'est des documents de planification qui
réaffirment le enfin de mener la
politique de l'eau à l'échelle du bassin
versant donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on défend naturellement avec beaucoup
d'acteurs de l'eau défendent c'est
vraiment le la façon cohérente d'aborder
d'aborder les politiques de l'eau avec
on se préoccupe pas seulement de la
ressource mais aussi de du territoire
sur lequel cette eau tombe sur lequel
elle ruisselle ou pas sur lequel elle
s'infiltre ou pas et donc et de
l'ensemble des usages donc le voilà
planifier les politiques de l'eau à
l'aide de ces gros documents que sont
les stages et leur déclinaisons
finalement un peu locale que sont les
sages c'est c'est une bonne approche
après une fois qu'on a dit ça
on leur on est les premiers à dire que
pour la plupart d'entre eux aussi va
être un peu différent forcément d'une
part vu le la situation du territoire en
question du bassin hygrographique mais
aussi des rapports de force qui peuvent
préexister entre différents
usagers entre l'amont et Laval est-ce
que voilà si c'est un territoire très
industriel très agricole qui arrive à un
peu mieux défendre ses intérêts donc il
y a une difficulté à construire des
consensus et on se retrouve avec des des
âges qui vont parfois être votés
vraiment de façon très collective par
l'ensemble du comité de bassin et donc
il y a vraiment une construction du
consensus qui va assez loin même si
chacun après va trouver que c'est
insuffisant sur tel ou tel orientation
et il y a des âges qui vont être
accueillis de façon un peu plus molle
par nos associations il peut y avoir
voilà des soit des abstentions ou même
dans
dans des cas particuliers des votes
contre
s'il y a vraiment des voilà des
orientations qui posent problème donc le
c'est un document qui donne des
orientations mais qui est pas très
prescriptif forcément donc la
question après c'est comment est-ce que
les sages arrivent à décliner ces
orientations en réglementation et en
mesure plus plus opérationnelles plus
concrète et se pose donc la question de
lance la couverture de l'intégralité
du territoire par les sages et
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas dans le
soyez favorable nous on y est favorable
on dit pas que ça va tout régler mais on
considère que en tout cas c'est donner
un message fort que c'est à chaque
territoire de s'emparer des questions
des questions de lot et que c'est à ce
niveau là que ça se fait le mieux donc
pour pousser un peu le sujet un peu
dynamique mais pour pousser un peu le
sujet vous soyez favorable
l'élargissement du nombre de PTB
l'élargissement du nombre d'épages et
une organisation on va dire plus
cohérente au niveau des territoires pour
qu'on ait une certaine forme
d'homogénéité même s'il y a des
différenciations dans les modes de
gouvernance etc voilà alors je
aujourd'hui on n'a pas forcément un avis
très précis sur ce qu'il faudrait des
EPTB ou des ehpages qui fonctionneraient
de la même façon et avec voilà le même
dimensionnement par territoire il peut y
avoir finalement des sages qui sont pas
animés que par les EPTB mais par les
élus les collectivités et derrière ça en
fait je poserai plutôt la question de ce
qui manque aujourd'hui au sage c'est
c'est peut-être le
dans certains territoires là où il y en
a pas si on commence un peu à les
imposer et c'est un peu ce que prévoit
le plan haut la généralisation des sages
ça va finalement
nécessiter de secouer les territoires
qui aujourd'hui n'en n'ont pas pour s'y
mettre et ça impliquera quand même qui
est à la fois une quand même une volonté
politique locale de
porter ces de porter ses commissions
locales de l'eau et d'élaborer des sages
qui soient un peu un peu musclés et
qui est aussi des moyens d'animation de
formation parce que une commission
locale de l'eau notamment quand elle ne
préexistait pas bah ça implique de voilà
de réunir des gens mais de les former de
leur apprendre à parler ensemble donc il
y a un peu une question aussi de moyens
est-ce que les justement si c'est les
EPTB qui sont en charge de l'animation
est-ce que il y aura ces moyens de
d'animation derrière donc après
précision
EPTB pour ce qui est des bassins
relativement importants mais après le
but du jeu c'est qu'il y ait des EHPAD
des syndicats de rivière qui sont aussi
les porteurs de sages c'est pas que les
éponges mais dans une logique de
subsidiarité après voilà alors il y a
toujours cette idée à revenir de ces au
plus près des territoires que peuvent
être prises les meilleures décisions
mais
sans non plus ne s'y référé uniquement à
cette petite échelle parce qu'il y a
évidemment toutes les questions de
solidarité à moins avale de voilà c'est
ça la subsidiarité et il faut que le ce
qu'on dit le sage et la déclinaison un
désorientation du stage mais il faut que
ça soit concrètement et aujourd'hui par
exemple il y a assez peu de sages qui
ont des mesures fortes en matière de
gestion quantitative
enfin c'est moins d'une dizaine en
France qui vraiment ont des mesures
réglementaires et qui vont être qui vont
être assez fortes là-dessus donc
aujourd'hui ce qui est un peu annoncé
dans le plan où ça c'est quelque chose
qui est plutôt satisfaisant on aurait
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir après
mais vu qu'on parle de la gouvernance
l'idée qu'il y ait la généralisation des
sages d'une part et d'autre part que ce
soit la commission locale de l'eau et
voilà le sage qui sera mobilisé pour
définir clairement les les volumes
préleva parce que c'est un peu tout
l'enjeu de la gestion quantitative c'est
savoir sur un territoire qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on s'autorise à prélever
pour quels usages comment répartis et
donc ça me permet de glisser sur le
sujet des ptge nous on est favorable on
défend le principe du ptgo qui a un
outil de concertation et donc au sens de
son de son instruction ministérielle
c'est un outil qui est intéressant
notamment
là où il y a pas de Sage où il y a pas
de commission locale de l'eau et où il
peut y avoir un peu une lacune en
matière de dialogue et de et de
concertation
ceci dit là où il y a un sage qui
fonctionne bien il y a pas forcément
besoin d'un PT GE pour mener une bonne
gestion quantitative de l'eau et là où
un PTG veut fonctionne bien
nous on est plutôt dans la proposition
que ça devienne la première brique d'un
d'un sage après donc même si des fois
les échelles sont pas les mêmes mais en
tout cas le pour nous le ptgo est un est
un bon outil mais c'est c'est enfin
c'est un outil qui est quand même centré
sur sur l'eau en tant que ressources
et donc ça peut pas faire l'ensemble de
la politique de l'eau et c'est mieux ou
c'est bien si s'il est sage derrière ne
sont pas enfin voilà sont pas dépossédés
la question ou s'ils étaient absents qui
se mettent à vivre à partir de cette
première concertation là quoi
une question peut-être que toi tu vas y
répondre d'ailleurs est-ce que dans tous
les départements il y a eu une carte de
fête sur les sources les rues les mares
les choses comme ça est-ce que ça existe
moi ça existe dans mon département enfin
dans mon secteur parce que je suis dans
un parc naturel et que nous avons
cartographié tout ça mais est-ce que ça
existe ça
on l'a vu avec la Fédération des étangs
pas d'une manière exhaustive
par exemple sur les étangs tous les
points d'eau sont pas forcément
répertoriés alors du coup dans le cas du
varen de l'eau il y a eu un travail
exploratoire qui a été fait de
l'ensemble des points d'eau mais avec
une encore des difficultés pour estimer
réellement le stock parce qu'on a du mal
à mesurer la profondeur et donc ce sont
des estimations qui peuvent être faites
donc et là on a des connaissances à
approfondir notamment à l'échelle des
bassins c'est les nappes profondes sont
encore mal connues les volumétries sont
mal connues sur l'ensemble des cours
d'eau les petits rues etc oui c'est
plutôt assez bien cartographié ça
c'est plus là où il y a eu la main de
l'homme à un moment donné ou des
éléments ont pu disparaître
voilà mais
l'affirmation de la connaissance à
l'échelle du bassin versant est quand
même une orientation intéressante
et pour pour rebondir vous avez évoqué
le l'inventaire national des plans d'eau
donc qui a été conduit dans le cadre des
conclusions du varen de l'eau mais qui
préexistait déjà dans les intentions de
la feuille de route des assises de l'eau
un peu mis du temps à se mettre en
marche et c'est dommage parce que les
premiers résultats quand sortent même si
c'est pas encore complètement stabilisé
c'est qu'on a énormément de plans d'eau
y compris les plans d'eau artificiels
déjà existants donc on stocke déjà
beaucoup de en surface et par contre on
mobilise pas forcément cette eau là de
façon optimale donc ça c'est c'est une
première chose d'une façon générale la
il y a beaucoup de lacunes de
connaissances sur l'eau alors que ce
soit sur alors il y a la cartographie
des cours d'eau où ça il y a eu la
question notamment de du statut de
certains cours d'eau ou pas qui sont
fait déclasser en fossé agricole pour
réglementairement voilà des rejets à
certaines règles mais au-delà de ça il y
a même si on a connaissance ou pas de
l'existence des cours d'eau après c'est
leur état d'écoulement
tout au long de l'année qui est assez
mal connue l'état des nappes vous l'avez
dit et
aussi le nombre de prélèvements et de
savoir qui prélève quoi à quel moment ça
c'est un peu la grosse inconnue et où
nous on identifie ça comme un point de
fragilité de la politique de l'eau en
fait puisque il y a tous les forages qui
sont en dessous de 10000 mètres cubes
d'eau par an ne sont pas soumis
autorisation juste à déclaration et donc
on sait pas en fait parce que entre 0 et
10000 m3 ça peut être des grosses
variations et c'est des petits forages
qui passent un peu sous les radars on
l'avait signalé dans le cadre des des
concertations préalables au plan haut
c'est c'est un gros sujet dans pas mal
de territoires ça peut devenir des
millions de mètres cubes et surtout
savoir ses forages là
quand est-ce qu'ils sont mobilisés ou
pas dans l'année parce que c'est des
forages parfois AG le seul parfois non
agricoles parfois plutôt pour de
l'élevage donc c'est pas forcément
mobilisé de la même façon que des
forages pour l'irrigation proprement
dite et le donc voilà cette lacune de
connaissance
à laquelle le plan o espère un peu
répondre à nous ça aussi c'est une des
choses du plan qu'on a accueilli un peu
favorablement c'est l'idée de de mieux
enfin de vraiment améliorer la
connaissance de systématiser les
compteurs les compteurs connectés avec
voilà téléversion quasiment en direct
des prélèvements ça va être des outils
de pilotage qui vont vraiment permettre
de de mieux mener la politique de la
préservation de la ressource et son
partage et dans le cadre des ptge c'est
aussi quelque chose qui est très
important parce que aujourd'hui
ce qui est compliqué c'est le le manque
de d'objectivation en fait de quels sont
les quelle est la ressource réellement
disponible quels sont les prélèvements
réels et donc les besoins réels parce
que il peut y avoir certains usages de
l'eau en particulier l'usage irrigation
qui a tendance à vouloir
surestimer les volumes dont il a besoin
pour entre guillemets s'assurer pour
plus tard de jamais manquer d'eau et
donc c'est ça qui après créer la
conflictualité autour de du
dimensionnement des ouvrages éventuels
de et du partage de l'eau y compris
entre agriculteurs d'ailleurs alors ça
c'est une orientation que on essaye
vraiment de creuser dans la connaissance
du bassin versant c'est à la fois tous
les paramètres qui permettent de mieux
comprendre et de mieux connaître la
quantité et la qualité des eaux dans
tous ces aspects pour piloter à la fois
la ressource et les usages dans les
meilleures conditions possibles donc ça
va dans dans le sens que vous indiquez
peut-être une dernière question et
peut-être que des collègues vont
peut-être réagir j'essaierai la
présidente
les sollicités quand vous aviez évoqué
aussi la DCE aujourd'hui maintenant
différents sujets d'actualité remonte
aussi mais parce que du coup il y a un
approfondissement aussi à certains
moments de la connaissance et puis des
analyses quel est votre regard par
rapport à ça notamment sur des nouveaux
métaboliques aussi qui interroge
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous estimez que le niveau de
contrôle est satisfaisant aujourd'hui et
derrière le niveau de contrôle
est-ce que vous estimez qu'il faut
étendre le nombre de périmètres de
protection aujourd'hui sur les
périmètres de captage prioritaire
quel autre point de vue alors tout
d'abord vis-à-vis de la DCE alors c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de territoires
où le
déclassement des masses d'eau est liés à
l'état chimique et donc c'est
préoccupant mais pour rappel en
préalable le mauvais état des masse
d'eau il est quand même aussi pas mal
lié à
au mauvais état écologique c'est à dire
même si on a un bon si on arrive à
atteindre un état chimique satisfaisant
le fait avoir des cours d'eau très
rectifiés canalisés
très artificialisé sur sur leur berge
des cours d'eau aussi qui sont soumis à
pas mal de
variations thermiques de variation
quantitative parce qu'il y a des
prélèvements ou des des ouvrages qui
font stagner l'eau donc tout ça voilà
quel que soit la politique qu'on a
vis-à-vis des des polluants ça restera
un problème et il faut vraiment avoir ça
en tête le la directive 4 sur l'eau
c'est pas juste une autre bonne qualité
chimique c'est vraiment une eau ou les
la faune et la flore peut
voilà peut y connaître un libre et un
bon développement
pour ce qui est des des pollutions
diffuses on a
on a globalement une situation assez
inquiétante
de façon générale parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à
on a des politiques qui sont assez peu
efficaces que ce soit vis-à-vis des
nitrates que ce soit vis-à-vis des
pesticides on retrouve quand même
toujours beaucoup de substances y
compris des substances qui sont
interdites depuis plusieurs années on
les retrouve et on retrouve leur
métabolites à des concentrations qui
sont inquiétantes et on les retrouve
finalement quand on se met à aller
chercher et c'est toute la question
c'est des fois on sait pas trop quel
substance aller chercher
nous là où on se dit qu'il faut un peu
franchir un nouveau cap c'est de
d'arriver à sortir alors c'est des il y
a des travaux de recherche et
d'innovation qui vont dans ce sens là de
pas juste mesurer parce que la
concentration du du 1 microgramme 01
microgramme par litre c'est une c'est un
seuil un peu arbitraire qui correspond
voilà des
on sait pas en fait si au dessus ou
enfin si en dessous ou si finalement
c'est un soyau de sucre la molécule a
vraiment un effet sur la santé et
surtout on se pose pas du tout la
question de cet effet cocktail du fait
d'avoir plein de substances et de
métabolites qui se retrouvent dans dans
les mêmes masses d'eau donc dans ce sens
là nous on prendrait vraiment plus
d'aller vers ces ces nouvelles méthodes
de mesure des échantillonnaires passifs
qui accumulent
donc c'est des choses qui sont un peu
qui visent pas à mesurer de molécules
par molécules dans le dans les eaux
brutes en fait ou finalement on va on va
trouver que ce qu'on cherche et on
risque de passer à côté de pas mal de
substances mais plus de d'essayer
d'avoir ces approches un peu un peu
synthétiques systémique avec des
échantillonneurs passifs qui vont
mesurer l'effet cocktail notamment sur
des sur des modèles biologiques par
exemple où on va mesurer du stress
enzymatique sur des organismes type
larves de grenouilles ou gamma donc ça
aujourd'hui c'est des choses qui fait
ses recherches à l'heure actuelle
l'inrae et puis un certain nombre de
startups qui voilà en écotoxycologie
pour l'instant c'est pas des choses qui
sont rentrées dans le dans les mesures
réglementaires mais finalement c'est
quelque chose où on si on si on
développe ce type de mesure alors faut
pas juste le faire parce que c'est
l'innovation faut le faire parce que on
a on a montré qu'il y a qu'il y avait eu
une mesure précise en fait de l'effet
sur les organismes vivants de des
polluants ça va permettre de
de mieux comprendre ce qui se passe d'un
point de vue physiologique et sûrement
de voilà de de plus être fixé sur une
liste de molécules qu'on ira chercher ou
pas et qu'on détectera ou pas maintenant
le en attendant d'avoir ça en place il y
a ce constat que on a énormément de
molécules et de métabolites qui sont
présentes à des quantités
qui qui sont inquiétantes et qui enfin
qui posent vraiment la question de de
quelle trajectoire on arrive à donner
aux
modèles agricole pour sortir de cet
usage de substances et surtout on a un
certain nombre de substances qui dès
qu'il y en a qui sortent il y en a enfin
voilà qui sont interdites on finit on en
autorise d'autres et on n'a pas et on
n'a pas le recul qu'il faut aujourd'hui
sur l'effet de d'un grand nombre de
molécules
[Musique]
des questions oui merci merci Madame
présidente moi je vais vous poser une
question concernant l'utilisation de
l'eau vous en avez parlé dans un
contexte de pénurie qui mérite
certainement d'être priorisé et ce bien
sûr même s'il a pris la priorité des
priorités c'est la sobriété
sur beaucoup de territoires on se rend
compte que on n'a pas toujours la
connaissance de la réserve disponible
vous l'avez mentionné alors moi
j'aimerais j'ai deux ou trois petites
questions la première c'est est-ce que
l'organisation actuelle de la gestion de
l'eau et la réglementation qui en
découle vous paraît satisfaisante est-ce
que vous pensez que les documents
d'urbanisme
prennent suffisamment en compte la
problématique de l'eau
et puis une dernière qui est peut-être
plus générale est-ce que la léma de 2006
mériterait pas à vos yeux quelques
évolutions et si oui lesquelles alors
j'essaie de répondre dans l'ordre alors
d'abord l'articulation des usages et ça
avec les documents d'urbanisme c'est sûr
que c'est pas assez aujourd'hui et
notamment parce que
c'est peut-être aussi parce que les
idages et les sages aujourd'hui ne
mettent pas assez l'accent sur la
question des sols des zones humides et
donc on se retrouve avec beaucoup de
documents d'urbanisme qui ne tiennent
pas compte de ces
caractères là enfin de ces paramètres là
qui sont pourtant des paramètres très
liés à la politique de l'eau donc oui il
y a sûrement vraiment
enfin de deux mondes finalement à se
faire beaucoup plus rencontrer et créer
une langue commune entre ces deux types
de documents
est-ce que les maths 2006 doit être
révisée
on nous a posé plusieurs fois la
question dans divers Castres des tables
rondes ces derniers mois et
honnêtement non c'est une loi qui est
équilibrée et qui fixe quand même des
objectifs
voilà qui qui mérite d'être poursuivi
et c'est pas tant aujourd'hui la
politique de l'eau ou la loi sur l'eau
qui qui doit être mise en question c'est
plutôt l'ensemble des autres politiques
publiques et leur articulation avec elle
donc vous avez parlé de document
d'urbanisme il y a toutes les politiques
d'aménagement et en particulier
l'artificialisation
parce que c'est un vrai sujet en fait
c'est quand un artificialise des sols on
limite de fait de la capacité de la
ressource en nos renouvelables à ce à se
régénérer puisque on infiltre pas l'eau
et le ruisselle donc ça c'est un premier
sujet la politique agricole commune
parce que si on compare les budgets de
toutes les agences de l'eau cumulé
versus le budget de la PAC on est sur un
rapport de 1 à 9 donc si on a une PAC
qui soutient un modèle qui de fait c'est
pas pour jeter l'eau propre sur sur les
agriculteurs mais qui de fait conduit à
des dégradations de l'eau en qualité en
quantité si on a une pacte qui va avec
un budget de 9 fois supérieur vient
dégrader la qualité de l'eau on aura
beau avoir la politique de l'eau la plus
carrée les agences de l'eau les plus
compétentes et ben voilà les meilleurs
mesures ça fait pas forcément le poids
donc il y a tous rééquilibrage cet
articulation des politiques publiques la
politique énergétique aussi évidemment
donc voilà
je veux bien poser deux questions la
première le plan haut évoque des
protections renforcées sur un certain
nombre de zones de captage et moi c'est
une interrogation est-ce qu'il faut
protéger les zones de captage ou est-ce
qu'il faut
prévenir au fond sur sur l'ensemble du
du territoire je suis pas expert c'est
pas comment tout ça ruisselle mais j'ai
beaucoup de mal à imaginer que
qu'au-delà des eaux enfin je vois bien
l'importance protéger les zones de
Carthage j'ai beaucoup de mal à imaginer
que la multiplication des des intrants
des herbicides des pesticides hors zone
de captage ne finissent pas un moment
donné quand même dans les nables voilà
donc ce qu'il faut est-ce que vous
défendez quelque chose puis ma deuxième
ma deuxième question souvent dans les
auditions on sent que sur la question
des usages la protection des milieux
naturels
apparaît moins
utilitaire pour ceux qui ont besoin
d'eau pour produire de l'agriculture
pour alimenter les humains dans le
réseau d'eau potable etc et j'entends à
l'inverse des gens qui disent mais vous
vous trompez au fond si on ne met pas en
priorité et la préservation des milieux
naturels on va continuer à dégrader
l'accès à la ressource en eau parce que
les sols absorbent moins etc ce que vous
pouvez me confirmer est-ce que vous avez
des éléments sur lesquels vous appuyez
pour être démonstrateur au fond là où
vous participez aux instances de de
coopération et de définition des des
priorités dans les clés ou dans les
projets de gestion de territoire comment
c'est reçu ce discours sur la
préservation des milieux est-ce que
c'est un combat amener quels sont vos
arguments pour le porter voilà c'est
c'est tout à fait vrai donc par rapport
je vais d'abord répondre sur les aires
de captage pour nous ça doit évidemment
pas être le seul endroit qu'on préserve
mais comme ça touche directement à
l'alimentation humaine l'eau est le
premier des aliments et donc c'est enfin
c'est une question de santé et c'est des
zones finalement c'est intéressant de
penser le changement de modèle en
priorité donc pour nous et puisque vous
parlez des milieux naturels ça fait
partie vraiment des deux éléments qu'on
a portés dans le plan o on a dit et
voilà essayons de
d'organiser cette sortie généralisée des
pesticides cette diminution drastique
qu'on appelle de nos vœux on fait deux
premières briques une brique dans les
zones Natura 2000 où il y a des
décisions du Conseil d'État qui qui de
toute façon incite à aller vers vers la
sortie des pesticides sur sur ces zones
et sur les aires d'alimentation de
captage voilà c'est c'est les deux
endroits où il faut construire une
agriculture sans pesticides qui sera la
première brique finalement
parce qu'après c'est enfin les les
pratiques vertueuses les les nouveaux
types d'exploitation ça fait ça inspire
les voisins aussi donc pour nous c'est
une première marche mais on voit déjà
que cette marche là elle est difficile à
sortir c'est-à-dire on
avait plutôt proposé lors des
concertations du plan haut de voilà une
échéance sortie des pesticides dans les
aires d'alimentation de captage à une
échelle de 10 ans parce que de toute
façon il y a il y a besoin d'aller vite
là dessus et il faut des annonces assez
fortes bon voilà on n'a pas eu
d'échéance on a plutôt une politique
volontariste d'accompagnement
aux bonnes pratiques sur ces airs-là
mais le plan au fixe pas un cap et d'une
façon générale sur les pollutions
diffuses il fixe pas des des Caps très
ambitieux sur la place que les milieux
naturels devraient occuper finalement
dans la politique de l'eau c'est toute
la question de ce qui s'appelle les
solutions fondées sur la nature c'est
cette idée que Ben la nature
les écosys par leur fonctionnement
finalement contiennent un certain nombre
de réponses d'une part à nos problèmes
et d'autre part méritent en soi d'être
préservé pour des raisons
éthiques patrimoniales
et c'est vrai que que ce soit le plan o
ou la façon d'aborder l'eau dans
beaucoup d'instance on est quand même
très centrés sur nos usages et pas le
les
usages que peuvent en avoir les autres
êtres vivants
c'est-à-dire enfin voilà la place qu'on
occupe on a une vision quand même très
anthropocentrée de l'eau et donc le il y
a là aussi un peu un
virage à prendre mais qui de toute façon
même d'un point de vue utilitariste sera
intéressant parce que le aujourd'hui
préserver la ressource et
maximiser la disponibilité naturelle de
la ressource ça implique de préserver
les zones humides de restaurer les
fonctionnalités des sols de remet André
des cours d'eau et de restaurer leur
continuité écologique et leur zone
d'expansion de crue tout ça c'est ce qui
va améliorer les échanges entre la
rivière et sa nappe d'accompagnement
c'est ce qui va vraiment ralentir de
façon naturelle le cycle de l'eau dans
sa face terrestre donc c'est nous c'est
des choses qu'on appelle de nos
et qui aujourd'hui sont un peu le parent
pauvre à la fois du plan o mais des
politiques de loi en général c'est à
dire il faut vraiment que
les politiques de l'eau deviennent une
politique des sols et de l'eau en fait
cette dimension là parce que c'est au
cœur de de cette question de cette
interaction entre l'eau le sol et enfin
et le reste des écosystèmes qu'on
va trouver des leviers en fait de
réponse
aujourd'hui un problème qui est très
centré sur une question ressources
pour être très franc avec vous bonjour
j'hésitais à la poser parce que j'étais
en train de lire la question était
formulée mais c'est bien parce que ça
permettra peut-être aussi d'avoir un
débat entre nous vous venez d'évoquer la
continuité écologique tel qu'elle est
décrite là dans notre question c'est en
gros est-ce que elle n'aurait pas un
effet pervers le fait de recréer une
sorte de vitesse des cours d'eau
n'entraînerait pas une baisse de la
biodiversité et moi en fait ce que je
suis en train de vivre dans le
territoire c'est un peu l'inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on aimerait bien qu'il y
a une continuité écologique parce qu'on
a sacralisé des cours d'eau on y touche
plus à tel point que je vous assure que
c'est vrai on est en train de rendre des
zones des communes inondables qui ne
l'était pas parce que l'eau ne part plus
et celle qui recevait le cours d'eau
elle est en train de s'assécher parce
que le cours d'eau n'arrive plus et et
c'est pas que des associations c'est
aussi les services de l'État on a
beaucoup de mal à cadre réel en leur
disant que simplement un entretien un
entretien régulier mais somme toute
voilà qui qui respecte aussi la
biodiversité serait pour moi utile
est-ce qu'entre ces différentes
positions de ne rien faire ou de faire
trop ou est-ce accompagne une vraie
utilité à faire je me permettre
d'enrichir en même temps la réponse
parce que elle revient sur un certain
nombre d'auditions on s'aperçoit que en
fait il faudrait avoir une
différenciation en fonction de la nature
de chaque territoire et qu'il y a pas la
même loi qui peut s'appliquer partout je
fais un peu court quand je dis ça alors
je dis ça et ça n'a rien de provocant
mais quand on dialogue aussi avec les
étangs etc on s'aperçoit qu'il peut y
avoir le fameux cours d'eau qui à un
moment donné mais dans certains
territoires les étangs jouent aussi un
rôle en termes d'aménité
environnementale etc particulièrement
important dans d'autres beaucoup moins
donc dans d'autres il y aurait une
évidence de pouvoir remettre en place
une continuité écologique
et dans d'autres et bien non ça serait
peut-être plus judicieux de les
préserver de les garder donc
ça reste un sujet qui est quand même
assez ouvert aujourd'hui alors c'est un
sujet alors ouvert ou sujet à
controverse ça va dépendre mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a aujourd'hui de la part
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs de l'eau
une tendance à présenter la politique
publique de restauration de la
continuité comme quelque chose d'assez
voilà d'assez autoritaire l'état
imposerait absolument la
libre circulation dans les cours d'eau
enfin poserait aux propriétaires de
seuil de détruire détruire leur seuil
alors qu'il y aurait un usage
intéressant et que une place paysagère
ou patrimoniale un petit rappel il y a
quand même plus de 100.000 seuils en
France donc je pense que l'État est loin
d'imposer quoi que ce soit en matière de
restauration de la continuité il y a
plutôt des opérations d'accompagnement
et un gros travail de priorisation sur
où est-ce qu'il est judicieux ou pas de
restaurer cette continuité alors il y a
sûrement voilà des exceptions on se dira
là ça peut être intéressant de de garder
telle ou telle retenue telle ou tel état
mais il y a quand même aujourd'hui alors
oui historiquement la main de l'homme a
beaucoup façonné notre paysage
hydrographique mais il y a aussi des
usages de ces étangs qui aujourd'hui
sont moins évidents il y a un
réchauffement climatique qui fait que il
y a un certain nombre de retenus ou
l'eau qui est stocké et n'est pas
forcément bien utilisé c'est de l'eau
qui s'évapore c'est de l'eau qui subit
aussi parce qu'elle stagne une certaine
dégradation qui est aussi le le
territoire de développement d'espèces
invasives donc il y a pas mal de raisons
qui poussent
l'État les collectivités les agences de
l'eau apporter cette politique de
restauration de la continuité
aujourd'hui c'est un des enfin c'est un
des gros freins à l'atteinte de la
du bon état des milieux et même
vis-à-vis du bouleversement climatique
de l'eau que ce soit sur la phase
inondation ou sur les faces sécheresses
on a tendance à se dire si on met des
seuils si on fait des étangs ça va
ralentir et donc ça va un peu constituer
une solution à la réfraction des
ressources ou à s'assure abondance mais
en fait il vaut mieux avoir un
non c'est pas un insec mais ce qu'on
constate non non
il y a des il y a de nombreux cours
d'eau mais alors il y a des cours d'eau
qui ont des qui ont des insectes
naturels et
enfin c'est là aussi c'est une question
c'est le sujet de travaux de l'INRA et
c'est assez poussé là-dessus notamment
je peux renvoyer aux travaux de Thibault
Datry
mais en même temps il y en a d'autres
qui pour lesquelles il vaudrait mieux
pas qu'ils en ait si je vous cite
prenons l'exemple de la garantie il y a
pas de soutien des tirages à un moment
donné je dis pas que la grande sera
assez mais enfin on sera vraiment en
dessous des débits même des débits
réservés oui non mais alors si on fait
comment
c'est bien pour ça qu'il y a c'est pour
ça que je dis que c'est aussi un peu
sujet on va dire débat à controverser
vis-à-vis du ce qu'on appelle le soutien
les tiages donc de maintenir un certain
nombre de retenu pour garantir
un débit tout au long de l'année comme
réponse
au changement climatique et aussi ça
peut permettre dans certains cas aux
espèces de de s'adapter c'est-à-dire si
aujourd'hui on restaure sur certains
cours d'eau si on supprimé l'ensemble
des ouvrages évidemment ça crée des
bouleversements que un certain nombre
d'espèces ne seraient pas capable
d'encaisser donc on n'a jamais eu à
France Nature Environnement
la défense de d'un paysage
hydrographique qui serait complètement
sauvage pas aménagé ce qu'on constate
par contre c'est qu'il y a un certain
nombre de seuils qui aujourd'hui n'ont
aucune utilité y compris sur le y
compris sur le sur l'hydrologie mais oui
non mais c'est pour ça il y a pas de
solution il y a enfin il y a pas de
position absolutiste aujourd'hui la
question c'est plutôt
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour garantir
à l'accès à un certain nombre de de
poissons migrateurs de pouvoir et les
poissons migrateurs c'est pas que ceux
qui viennent de la mer c'est aussi au
sein de l'eau douce il y a des poissons
qui ont besoin de se déplacer le long du
cours d'eau pour assurer leur cycle de
vie c'est pas que les poissons c'est
aussi la faune et la flore qui ont
besoin de cette continuité c'est la
continuité sédimentaire c'est la
continuité thermique c'est à dire quand
on multiplie des seuils sur un cours
d'eau c'est l'eau qui stagne c'est l'eau
qui peut aussi se réchauffer qui peut
s'appauvrir en oxygène c'est des risques
de colmatage donc tous ces sujets là
c'est des la contribution à la
dégradation de l'état écologique du
cours d'eau et donc dans un certain
nombre de cas vraiment la restauration
de la continuité c'est pas une lubie de
l'état des associations et de l'Office
français de la biodiversité c'est
vraiment une une solution pour retrouver
un maximum de de fonctionnalités des
milieux et voilà donc la question c'est
aujourd'hui comment on amène la
différenciation au niveau des
territoires en fonction de la nature des
projets et juste pour terminer
parce que le temps passe malheureusement
derrière ça donc les sages peut-être
peut-être sont les mieux placés pour
justement regarder la pertinence ou non
de rétablir la continuité ou quelles
conditions on doit poser donc c'est un
point et la question qui est
sous-jacente dans l'acceptabilité
notamment au niveau des ptge comment on
cristallise les positions souvent
aujourd'hui on peut remarquer que sur le
terrain on va pouvoir trouver parfois
des consensus territoriaux sur des
projets mais qui sur un processus
juridique vont être cassé après au
niveau national par des recours que
certains vont juger excessifs ou du
moins trop tardif c'est à dire que la
base même de la négociation et de la
cristallisation
n'est pas toujours à l'échelle que l'on
pourrait souhaiter ce qui fait que il y
a des craintes et parfois des projets
qui mettent énormément de temps à sortir
voilà n'arrive même plus à sortir
d'ailleurs
alors
il y a deux choses un peu différentes
d'abord sur le comment est-ce qu'on
priorise etc et pour ce qui est de la
continuité écologique il y a les listes
1 Liste 2 les statuts de réservoir
biologique pour les cours d'eau qui
amènent
encore une fois un vue l'argent qui faut
mettre en plus c'est quelque chose qui
est stratégisé par les politiques
d'agence par enfin l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'eau donc voilà aujourd'hui
je dirais qu'il y a pas il y a pas une
politique intelligente qui est faite
là-dessus encore faut-il que
l'instabilité réglementaire vis-à-vis de
cette politique de la continuité
écologique viennent pas un peu freiner
parce qu'il y a ça aussi il y a pas que
les recours d'associations qui peuvent
empêcher des projets peut y avoir aussi
et on l'a vu lors de la loi climat et
résilience un des amendements un peu un
peu cavaliers qui qui sont venus dans
dans la loi sous prétexte de protéger un
petit potentiel hydroélectrique
vous serez ce les seuils de moulin
empêcher voilà voilà donc on va pas
revenir sur cet épisode là mais c'est à
dire l'instabilité
vis-à-vis des projets ça peut aussi être
sur des projets de restauration
concernant les ptgge et le consensus qui
serait brisé par des recours
administratifs c'est quand même enfin je
le dis je dis de toute façon c'est assez
franche c'est assez faux de notre point
de vue aujourd'hui si il y a des recours
qui sont portés par France Nature
Environnement par exemple au National
c'est en accompagnement d'une de nos
fédérations locales on prend pas la
décision de venir bousculer un consensus
avec laquelle nos fédérations seraient
d'accord donc si un consensus qui est
construit avec nos fédérations
généralement il y a
pas de question en revanche
il y a des c'est pour ça il faut
vraiment voir ce qu'on appelle le
consensus local si le consensus local
c'est se mettre d'accord à plusieurs
pas tout le monde pour finalement faire
quelque chose qui est hors des clous du
code de l'environnement et bah oui là
les associations ont été réagir et que
ce soit notre fédération locale où nous
en au National on pourra aller au
contentieux et si on gagne c'est bien
que localement il y a eu des
il y a eu il y a eu finalement un projet
qui contrevenait à la loi et vis-à-vis
du ptgo c'est là-dessus où nous on
apporte un peu un point de vigilance et
dans le guide
pour améliorer les PTCE le ministère est
en train de produire
on a insisté lors de des phases de
discussion sur ce guide sur le fait
qu'un ptge c'était pas enfin ça pas une
valeur réglementaire c'est une phase de
concertation qui aide à faire émerger un
projet consensuel mais
c'est à dire ça ne passe pas au dessus
de la loi sur l'eau ça ne passe pas au
dessus des directives habitats ça ne
passe pas au dessus des ça ne donne pas
dérogation à destruction d'espèces
protégées si les construction d'un
ouvrage donc c'est vrai sur ce sujet là
mais vous savez qu'il y a ce qui est
posé aussi sur la table c'est le conflit
parfois entre les différents codes sur
un certain nombre des sujets et donc qui
posent parfois question la difficulté
d'avoir une approche sociétale et pas
uniquement environnementale parfois sur
certains sujets et comment on
réintroduit dans les projets tous les
avantages je parlais tout à l'heure des
aménités mais toutes les avantages que
le projet peut évidemment avoir par
exemple même au niveau du coup carbone
avec peut-être des projets qui peut
avoir une influence positive à moyen et
long terme mais c'est donner là sont pas
forcément réintroduites à un moment
donné dans l'approche purement juridique
environnementale alors que si on était
dans un référentiel plus complexe le
projet pourrait on pourrait se dire
qu'il a un bénéfice global et général
même au sens climatique vous voyez
favorable et là on sent des difficultés
on sent que là il y a quand même un
problème pour arriver à faire une
évaluation on va dire à 360 quoi
l'évaluation à 360 comme vous dites elle
peut passer par exemple par les études
hydrologie milieu
usage climat les études haché Musset qui
sont les études sur le bassin Loire
Bretagne qui synthétise un peu justement
le tous diagnostic commun qu'il faut
avoir sur quelle est la ressource
vraiment disponible quels sont les
usages réels qui en sont faits
commencent à évoluer avec le climat et
et surtout quelle est la place des
milieux autour de tout ça parce que des
fois les études hachému c'est le m du
milieu
il saute un peu
mais est-ce que est-ce que on fait cet
effort là et normalement un petit jeu
qui est bien mené avec une étude et
Musée solide derrière pour pour soutenir
le la discussion on
devrait pas arriver à des choses qui qui
mènent à lui contentieux quand je veux
dire je vais prendre des exemples de
contentieux récemment que quoi un peu
des défrayer
la chronique médiatiquement c'est sur le
barrage de la tête dans les Pyrénées
orientales ou on a un préfet qui demande
une étude pour évaluer le débit réservé
le débit minimum biologique que doit
laisser passer un barrage
l'étude lui dit tel volume et lui il
prend une dérogation pour dire bah oui
non on va on va en laisser passer qu'un
tiers de ce débit qui est recommandait
par par les scientifiques
et forcément c'est quelque chose qui au
tribunal ne passe pas donc
parce que c'est enfin c'est une vie on a
un préfet qui juste voilà désobéit à une
étude scientifique aux recommandations
aux conclusions d'une étude qu'il a
lui-même commandée
le contentieux là on a je veux dire on a
dit à la fois pour l'intérêt de la
nature mais aussi pour l'intérêt
l'intérêt général je veux dire c'est de
la défense du finalement de l'esprit de
la Charte de l'environnement derrière
donc voilà le c'est un contentieux qui
n'a pas plu et c'est une victoire
juridique de France Nature Environnement
qui n'a pas plu notamment monde agricole
je suis d'accord mais pour moi c'est un
autre sujet c'est de pouvoir dérogatoire
du préfet qui peut être remis en
question par rapport à ça donc
les contentieux ce que j'essaie
d'illustrer c'est que les contentieux
qu'on mène nationalement c'est pas là
pour pilonner des consensus locaux qui
aurait été construit c'est plutôt quand
il y a eu vraiment des manquements
graves
on a des juristes qui aiment beaucoup
faire des contentieux mais c'est ils le
font pas par plaisir c'est-à-dire on
priorise et on a France Nature
Environnement en priorise les
contentieux qu'on fait si on avait plus
de moyens peut-être qu'en offrait plus
mais donc chaque contentieux qui est
mené c'est qu'il y a vraiment de notre
point de vue un intérêt à agir parce que
c'est des voilà c'est des choses qui qui
ne devraient pas avoir lieu dans les
territoires donc on ne vient pas enfin
voilà je pense pas aujourd'hui que les
contentieux avec le risque de
contentieux associatif sur des ouvrages
qui ou sur des projets qui sont pas
forcément des ouvrages qui aurait fait
consensus c'est en fait c'est qu'il y
avait pas un vrai consensus localement
et très d'être d'ailleurs analysé en
profondeur parce que parfois les on a
aussi chacun des a priori en fonction de
niveau d'actualité mais qui correspond
pas forcément une généralité d'ailleurs
on est à 3-4 minutes de la fin je pense
peut-être une dernière question et puis
on vous rappelant que vous pouvez nous
apporter par écrit tous les éléments
complémentaires
oui merci peut-être une dernière
question dans prolongement de ce que mon
collègue a indiqué sur les captages
alors c'est vrai que sur la protection
des captages on a des annonces dans le
plan haut mais qui en effet ne sont pas
très clairs on a aussi une transposition
qui va bientôt intervenir de la
directive eau potable est-ce que vous
pensez vous que c'est une opportunité de
mieux protéger les captages des
pollutions notamment pesticides est-ce
que vous pensez si je ne sais pas si
vous avez analysé le les ordonnances de
transposition qu'on en prend le chemin
et est-ce que vous avez vu des pistes
d'amélioration si ce n'est pas le cas
alors sur la transposition oui c'est une
opportunité après la juré pas forcément
de
enfin une analyse détaillée sur comment
ça peut être précisément un levier mais
il est enfin il est clair que
aujourd'hui va se poser la question même
un peu de la confiance du consommateur
en fait sur donc il y a besoin de une
politique assez volontariste vis-à-vis
de
vis-à-vis de l'eau potable vis-à-vis de
la qualité qui doit être réaffirmé et
pas juste par des solutions curatives
mais en montrant parce que c'est aussi
des choses qui sont plus coûteuses à me
faire du curatif que du préventif et par
ailleurs je veux dire on a des objectifs
de développement de d'agriculture
biologique qui voilà aujourd'hui c'est
on les on les atteint pas forcément donc
ça pourrait être une double opportunité
en fait on généralise
que l'agriculture sur les aires
d'alimentation de captage soit une
agriculture sans pesticides c'est on
répond aussi en même temps
à cet enjeu de développer le développer
l'agriculture biologique
on va envoyer communiquer dans tous les
compléments que vous souhaitez
assurer qu'on vraiment on est pendant en
considération
nos travaux vont il faut nous les
communiquer jusqu'à mi-mai oui
le plus tôt possible merci beaucoup en
tout cas merci à vous
merci pour votre sollicitation